-I can't wait to talk to you.
Thank you so much
for being on our show.
-Thank you for having me.
-This is your first-ever
Las Vegas residency,
which is kind of
hard to believe,
but it's your first ever.
It's kicking off in two weeks.
You showed me some
rehearsal footage backstage.
It is -- It's insane.
I don't know how --
It's not even a magic show.
It's -- I don't know how
to describe what you showed me.
It's like -- Trust me.
Get there and do it.
You will experience this.
I mean, what do we --
How do you even --
-Maybe we try something with
all of you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, let's try something
with everybody.
-Already? Already?
What are you doing already?
-Everybody, I think you all have
an envelope under your seats.
You do, too.
There's an envelope
under your seats.
It should be --
And it says, "Do not open."
Everybody hold that envelope up.
You all have -- Good, great.
Just rip it open, and there's
a deck of cards in the envelope.
Everybody open the box
and pour all of the cards
into your hand.
Make sure they don't spill.
And turn it face-down.
Good. The box is empty? Great.
Put the box on the floor.
You don't need it.
Turn all the cards face-down.
-Yeah.
-Hold it in your hand
just like that.
Perfect. Great.
Is everybody
holding the deck face-down?
Okay, I want everybody to just
pick up a bunch of cards.
And everybody show us --
Everybody show the card that you
cut to, so turn it over.
-Can I show it?
-Yeah, turn it over. Great.
Did you all do that,
just like Jimmy?
Leave that file face-up
and put it on top of the pile
in your hand with --
Just like that.
So, spread through the face-up
cards to the last face-up card.
Go ahead, spread through.
And you'll see
they're all different,
until you see the first
face-down card, just like Jimmy.
And put the face-up pile
on the bottom now.
Everybody
put them on the bottom.
Yeah, just like that. Perfect.
And watch they don't spill.
They're a little slippery.
Okay, so, we're going to
take five cards.
So count five cards.
One, two, three, four, five.
Yep, take five cards. Good.
Is -- Everybody has five cards?
Which is like a poker --
And leave them face-down
in your hands, everybody.
And get rid of the big pile.
Throw it on the floor,
whatever you want.
-Big cleanup here tonight.
-Great.
Okay, now choose anybody
in the audience at random.
I don't care.
Just call somebody out.
It's up to you. You choose.
-Alright, I will
say that guy over there
with the striped shirt
right there with the blond hair.
-Oh, great. Could you stand up?
-Yes.
-So, pick a number
between 1 and 5.
Say it out loud.
-4.
-4?
Everybody take the fourth card
and hide it in your pocket.
So, count, face-down,
1, 2, 3, 4.
And take the fourth card
and hide it in your pocket.
Don't let anybody see it.
Or sit on it
if you don't have pockets.
Everybody hide the card.
Everybody did that?
-Yes.
-Okay, get rid of
the other cards.
Get rid of all the other cards.
We don't need them.
Everybody drop them
on the floor.
-Floor, yeah, exactly.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, it's unbelievable.
-Now, now, Jimmy --
-It's great to
see you, buddy, yeah.
-Jimmy, we brought some pins.
-Mm-hmm.
-There's pins.
Could you grab
these little pins right here?
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-This is going to be fun.
-What are you doing to me, bud?
-I don't know.
And -- I don't know.
Can you look at them
and make sure they're real pins?
Don't hurt yourself.
Don't, like, snap one.
-Yeah. Okay. Yeah, this is --
-Yeah? It's a real pin?
-These are pins.
-And they're sharp.
-Yes, yes.
I know, Questlove.
Don't freak out.
Yeah.
Yes, these are sharp pins.
-Can you pull one
of the pins out?
-Please don't make me
do anything to you, David.
'Cause I honestly --
I love having you on the show.
I don't like hurting you.
-And can you --
Let's see if we can do it on
your desk, actually, here.
So, I'm going to try to
stick this in.
No, you know what?
Can you hand me
the deck of cards?
Great.
So, let's do like this here.
I'm going to use the -- And you
see all the cards in the deck.
So, we'll use -- Here.
We'll use maybe the joker card
as a best card.
So, here.
We'll use this card, the joker.
-Okay.
-So, we use the joker,
and I'm going to bend it
a little more, like that,
so it'll stick.
-Okay.
-So, now I'm going to
take the pin,
and stick it right in
the card like that.
Now it'll stick.
You see that?
-Okay.
-So, the pin is definitely
sticking into the card.
Jimmy, hold your hand like this.
No, you're not going to
do anything.
Yeah, yeah, your other hand,
the right hand.
Open -- Yeah, yeah.
Open, open, open.
Good. Make it -- Yeah.
And just feel gently.
Feel it.
Is that really a sharp pin?
Gently, gently.
It's really there?
-Yes.
-It's sharp?
-Yes?
-Yes.
-Okay, good.
So, Jimmy,
what we're going to do is,
we're going to slam...
-Aah!
-...your hand down onto
the pin as hard as you can.
-Aah!
-No, no.
Please don't do this, David.
-But let me just show
you like this.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Let's do it together.
Look. One, two, three.
-I've had,
like, hand injuries, David.
Please, please. I've had --
-Hold on.
We're going to do it like this.
Look. 1, 2, 3,
and we're gonna slam,
but right in the middle.
-Aah-ha, David! No!
-We're going to go together.
Ready?
-No, please, please, please.
-One, two...
No, I'm just kidding.
-My gosh!
-Aah!
♪♪
-I can't do it. I can't.
Gosh!
-Jimmy, come back.
-You freak me out!
You're going to make me do that!
-No, no,
I wouldn't make you do that.
-Don't make me do that, please!
Oh, my gosh.
-Jimmy, before we do that --
-Yes! What?!
-Jimmy, before we do that,
you see all the cards
in the deck are different, yes?
-Yes.
-I'm going to run through
the cards,
and I want you to just try to
see one inside.
But here.
Like, I'm going to
run through like this.
It might be hard to see.
Try to see one inside
if you can.
But don't say it.
-Yes.
-You got one?
-Okay. Give me your hand again.
We're going to slam together
as hard as we can,
and you're going to slam
as hard as you can with me.
You have to trust me on this.
Ready?
On one, two...
[ Drumroll ]
By the way,
nobody should try this.
No kid should do this.
I'm a trained magician.
-Oh, my gosh.
One -- we're going to go
together...
two -- Jimmy, together.
-Aah!
Oh, my gosh.
-Jimmy, what was the card
you thought of?
-5 of hearts.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-But -- but wait.
Wait, wait. Hold on.
But before Jimmy did this,
you all cut the cards
and you all took a card
at random.
I think you cut,
then you thought of a --
Then you hid the card.
And you -- Can you all
pull your card out together?
And can we see what card
you all have?
♪♪
-Come on!
Ladies and gentlemen,
that is exactly
how you do it right there.
David Blaine right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God.
You guys, David Blaine.
When does the show start?
-Well, hold on, Jimmy.
No, no, no.
Jimmy, so, you're okay.
There's nothing here.
But I wanted to up it
a little bit.
I brought something else.
Can you --
I brought a box of nails.
Jimmy, can you pull out
the box of nails and the bowl?
Yeah, take them out.
See, there's a bowl.
-Yes.
-Yeah, you can --
Here, I'll move this.
You can just --
Yeah, we just need the --
Yeah, just need --
Yeah, perfect.
[ Nails rattle ]
Can you check that
they're real nails, Jimmy?
-Let's go to commercial, and
then we'll figure it all out.
-We're not going anywhere.
[ Laughter ]
Dump them all into here.
Dump all the nails
into the bowl.
Can you mix them around, make
sure they're all real nails?
Check them. Mix them up.
Are they real nails?
-Oh, my gosh.
Yes, they are very sharp,
heavy, real metal nails.
-So, these are real nails.
Is that true?
-Yes.
-Are they sharp?
-Yes, they're very sharp.
-Oh, you picked one up?
Let me see that one.
Gimme. Gimme.
I'm going to bite it.
-Okay, okay.
-Yeah.
Yeah?
-Yes.
♪♪
-David -- David,
what in the world?
David Blaine
is eating nails right now.
This is insane.
This is -- this is all real.
This is crazy.
-You want some?
-No, thank you.
I don't want to eat...
How?
How...
-[ Coughs ]
How did you just...
Stop eating nails!
Stop eating -- David!
Oh, my God.
This is insane right now.
David Blaine is just eating
a bowl of nails right now.
♪♪
-[ Coughs ]
How in the --
-Wait, Jimmy.
Just...
[ Coughs ]
Just push right here for me.
Push right here, lightly.
Yeah, lightly. Go ahead.
Push lightly.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much
for, uh -- for --
-I feel like I still have...
[ Drumroll ]
-David, don't do this.
-No!
-No, don't do this.
Don't -- Not the --
Oh, my gosh, another nail.
Oh, my gosh. This is insane.
-It's not a nail.
Oh, it's not...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-What was that...
-David Blaine, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"David Blaine Live"
begins September 30th
at Resorts World
on the Las Vegas Strip.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show."
What just happened?